Donald Trump's press secretary and senior
campaign adviser and just a private person
who supports Trump is Kayleigh McEnany.
She has three roles which she uses interchangeably,
depending on what's more convenient.
Kayleigh McEnany did a dove directly into
the deep end of the crazy pool with this Trump
voter fraud stuff.
And you really have to see it to believe it.
Now, I know there's a long list of people
who deserve to never work again after this
Trump administration is all said and done.
Kayleigh McEnany is certainly at the top of
the list, a so-called Christian who lies daily
for Donald Trump.
And I know that when I say deserves to never
work again, some people write to me.
They say, David, are you advocating for people
to starve or are you saying she should be
on the streets without food?
No, Kaili can have food.
I'm saying that in a fair world, she should
be unemployable given her behavior as Trump
press secretary.
She's going to be fine financially.
She's married to a professional baseball player.
Don't worry, but she should be unemployable
for the absolute atrocities she's been involved
with during her time working for Trump.
Now, White House Press Secretary Kayleigh
McEnany goes on Fox News with Stuart Varney,
Fox Business with Stuart Varney.
And this time she's there not as press secretary,
but as a Trump campaign adviser.
And she is asked, is Donald Trump going to
go to President elect Joe Biden's inauguration?
And she says, well, the president will attend
his own inauguration.
Are you prepared to say that the president
will President Trump will definitely attend
the inauguration again?
You know, that's many that's many steps away
here.
We're talking January, and President Trump
believes he will be President Trump have a
second term in litigation.
Is the first step many steps away from that?
It would look pretty bad if he did not attend
the inauguration.
It would certainly look like sour grapes,
wouldn't it?
I think the president will attend his own
inauguration.
He would have to be there.
In fact, does anybody fall for that?
The answer is yes.
A recent poll shows 86 percent of Trump ists
believe Joe Biden did not legitimately win.
Sixty percent of Trump voters believe that
what Trump is doing will overturn the results
and will lead to Trump getting a second term.
We watch this.
You and I watch this.
Normal people watch this and we say, who could
possibly believe this stuff?
Well, eighty six percent of Trump voters,
which is about 62 million people, believe
it was stolen from Joe Biden.
43 million people are sitting there expecting
that Trump tweeting and filing bogus lawsuits
will lead to Trump being president for a second
term.
Then on Friday or maybe this was Saturday
night, the same Kayleigh McEnany appeared
on Fox News and referred to an election epidemic,
which is both.
Hilarious, but also she's on to something
in a certain way.
Let's take a look.
And Sean is they seized on a global pandemic
and created an election epidemic and we saw
it happening.
I remember the campaign attorneys coming to
the president and say we're fighting this
in court and this in court and they're trying
to extend the deadline here.
And it was like whack a mole, whack a mole.
Now, first of all, she'd be far more convincing
if she held up pieces of paper.
She should be holding up reams of paper to
be more credible.
That's usually her move.
But what she says in election epidemic, it
was an epidemic of people voting.
We had massive turnout.
It turns out if you make it easier for people
to vote, like expanding early voting and expanding
absentee and vote by mail, more people vote.
We've had over one hundred and fifty one million
votes counted so far.
That's the epidemic.
People will vote if you make it easier.
And it's very clear that that's not a great
thing for Donald Trump and for the Republican
Party.
Carly deserves to never work again.
I don't want her to starve.
I want her to be able to feed her children.
But she should be unemployable for the grift
that she has participated in for the last
several years.
But if you look online, you know that right
wing grifting can actually be very, very profitable.
Caylee's going to do just fine, my friends
The David Pakman Show at
David Pakman Dotcom.